die abstimmung ist offensichtlich
ausgezählt jetzt müssen sich die
abgeordneten alle wieder hinsetzen platz
nehmen damit dann das ergebnis verkündet
werden kann wir wollen mal reinhören und
immunisierung der bevölkerung gegen saas
kopf zwei in der ausschuss fassung
drucksachen 20 899 20 954 und 20
1353 abgegebene stimmkarten
683 mit ja haben gestimmt
296 mit nein haben gestimmt
378 enthaltungen 9
der gesetzentwurf ist in zweiter
beratung abgelehnt damit entfällt nach
unserer geschäftsordnung die weitere
beratung dieses gesetzentwurfs wir gehen
dann weiter
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen eine
gewisse ernsthaftigkeit bei einem
solchen thema wäre jetzt aber auch
angebracht
[Musik]
wir gehen jetzt weiter zur abstimmung
über den antrag der fraktion der cdu/csu
aufdrucks
978 mit dem titel im vorsorge gesetz ein
guter schutz für unser land es ist
namentliche abstimmung verlangt
die schriftführerin und schriftführer
sind an ihren plätzen die uhren sind
besetzt ich eröffne die namentliche
abstimmung für zehn minuten
bitte sehen sie zu dass sie zügig ihre
stimme abgeben vielen dank
[Musik]
bild key news
so sie haben gehört liebe zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer das war eine ganz klare
abstimmung die impfpflicht ab 60 sie
wird nicht kommen januar das ist schon
harter tobak das ist eine super klatsche
für karl lauterbach vor allem weil sie
auch so deutlich jetzt ausgefallen ist
also ich lese es noch mal vorher 683
abgegebene stimmen da fehlen knapp 50
also 50 abgeordnete sind offenbar nicht
da und die der der vorschlag der meisten
ampel abgeordnete muss man ja sagen der
kompromissvorschlag hinter dem auch der
bundesgesundheitsminister stand und der
bundeskanzler hat ganze
296 stimmen bekommen 378 also fast 100
mehr der ab und haben mit nein gestimmt
es gab nur einen haltung das ist eine
super klatsche dass es ganz klar karl
lauterbach muss man sagen ist mit dem
ganzen thema empfiehlt komplett
gescheitert mit dem heutigen tag schwarz
auf weiß das haben wir jetzt gesehen und
was wird jetzt genau noch abgestimmt
jetzt geht es weiter ganz genau jetzt
kommt der zweit weitestgehende
impfpflicht antrag das ist der von
cdu/csu angegeben rund 200 abgeordnete
stellt die cdu csu nur noch in dem
aktuellen bundestag und der hat mutmaßt
sich auch wenig chance durch zu gehen
aber dass ein antrag der gesagt hat wir
wollen erst ein impf register und halten
uns vor dass wir im herbst dann zu einer
allgemeinen impfpflicht kommen wenn wir
feststellen okay die korona zahlen gehe
wieder deutlich drauf also das ist so
ein auf vorrat impfpflicht antrag kann
man sagen dem würde ich jetzt auch
überhaupt keine chancen einräume denn es
müssten jetzt ja viele aus der ampel
koalition abstimmen die sie mutmaßlich
ziemlich frustriert also ich glaube dass
man da jetzt auch zu keinem positiven
positive ergebnis kommt es wäre wenn es
so wäre ein super triumph für friedrich
merz auf der anderen seite aber ich kann
mir vorstellen dass gerade die spd
abgeordnete sagen nein dem stimme
bewusst nicht zu um nicht diese klatsche
für olaf scholz und dieses super debakel
für lauterbach dann zusätzlich zu einem
sieg für friedrich merz umzumünzen also
ganz zum festhalten super klatsche für
karl lauterbach meiner meinung nach ist
das für ein gesundheitsminister dann in
dem amt auch nicht weiter tragbar für
ihn nicht das ist der bericht jetzt
wirklich etwas zusammen für olaf scholz
ist das eine niederlage muss man so
deutlich sagen und wir sehen wer heute
dann als lächelnder sieger rausgeht
vielleicht ist es wolfgang kubicki der
von anfang an gegen die impfpflicht war
was bedeutet das denn auch für den
zusammenhang der ampel muss man sagen
dass dieses thema jetzt die ihre neue
regierung ja schon spaltet sehr früh das
ist in der tat eine sehr gute frage das
wird sicherlich aufzuarbeiten sein denn
wir haben von vielen prominenten ampel
abgeordneten oder auch ministern ja
gehört dass sie sich für die impfpflicht
ausgesprochen haben auch robert habeck
hat ja im vorwahlkampf gesagt also
richtig also dass sie sich eigentlich
dann im endeffekt auch für eine
impfpflicht aussprechen die also dass da
gab es schon viele viele befürworter
aber wir stellen fest es hat bei weitem
nicht gereicht